eu era uma consumidora compulsiva
assim como a maior parte das pessoas ao
meu redor e muitos de vocês creio eu
e mais isso tudo a gente não pode
desculpar porque a gente vive numa
sociedade de consumo estimulado o tempo
todo a comprar e comprar tantas vezes o
ter acaba sendo os mais valioso por ser
e várias pessoas usam as coisas para
subir suprir suas carências emocionais
mas a gente precisa repensar isso tudo
eu trabalhei dez anos no mundo
corporativo achando que se eu tivesse
dinheiro suficiente para comprar todas
as coisas que eu queria eu seria feliz
mas nesse período eu tive uma grande
insatisfação eu percebi que eu sofria a
cada noite de domingo e aquilo foi me
gerando um incômodo e eu precisava fazer
alguma coisa para mudar eu percebi que
eu me distanciava cada vez mais de mim
mesmo
até que eu olhei pra dentro do meu
armário e vi que lá estava metade do meu
salário de todo o ganho que eu tive
durante a vida
aquilo me causou um enorme incómodo e eu
me desafiei a parar de comprar e o tempo
que eu gastava nos corredores do
shopping e página do e commerce eu
passei pra usar para o alto
desenvolvimento
livros palestras documentários passaram
a fazer parte da minha vida da minha
rotina e assim eu aprendi que a moda é a
segunda indústria que mais polui o meio
ambiente só perde para o preto no
petróleo incrível né pra vocês terem uma
idéia 10 por cento das emissões de gases
de efeito estufa vêm nela
isso é mais do que a viação e transporte
marítimo juntos
é muita coisa então eu estava fazendo
mal só pra mim estava prejudicando todo
o planeta com o meu consumismo
naquele momento eu resolvi repensar e me
desafiei
e aí eo aprofundei cada vez mais nesse
estudo e eu vi que não era um problema
só meu
era um problema global enquanto a venda
de roupas cresce o uso cai na mesma
proporção
isso significa que estamos acumulando
nos nossos armários litros e mais litros
de água e centenas de recursos naturais
que são usados para fazer cada peça de
roupa que a gente veste é um problema
sério para o mundo todo ea solução está
na nossa mão ea gente consegue mudar com
certeza e agora vou falar pra vocês um
pouco de como eu fiz pra mudar a chave
de tudo é o autoconhecimento ele a base
você precisa refletir qual é o seu
gatilho para a compra o que te faz
comprar demais
o meu era justificar um padrão de vida
que eu julgava necessário e pra mim não
tem aquele emprego com aquele salário
tem gente que substitui sessões de
terapia com compras
outros estão entediadas vou comprar
então a gente precisa repensar isso
outro ponto muito importante é trazer o
vestir para a consciência das nossas
escolhas costumam ser muito intuitivas
por que você gosta do que você gosta
você deve saber disso
qual é o seu estilo pessoal quais são as
cores que há em você mas seu corpo não é
como é com essa bem 100% das minhas
clientes têm roupas parada no armário
porque acordo combina com um colorido
natural delas ou porque não cai bem no
corpo
a gente precisa ter domínio do nosso
tipo físico de tudo isso
além disso toda vez que a gente vai
comprar alguma coisa a gente precisa ver
se é realmente aquilo que a gente está
precisando né pra vocês terem uma ideia
eu me preocupo muito com o mundo que a
gente quer ter também cada vez que a
gente gasta o nosso dinheiro a gente
está investindo no mundo que a gente
quer no futuro então a gente investe em
desde que a gente quer ver prosperar que
tipo de imprensa você quer como que
prospere no mundo que tenha sucesso pra
vocês é conseguir visualizar
tangibilizar um pouco isso a roupa que
estou sentindo agora é de uma marca
carioca
ou seja estou ajudando a economia local
the slow fashion significa que eu vou
usar ela durante muito tempo que ela tem
uma durabilidade maior e é atemporal
isso pra mim é um atributo muito
importante e além disso eles colocam na
etiqueta da roupa que acordo que permite
que você rastrear toda a cadeia de
produção e entenda exatamente o preço
que você tá pagando por ela
isso é o comércio justo e transparência
então invista nesse tipo de empresa
quando você for comprar alguma coisa
entenda a origem das más só pensar
quando a gente vai comprar alguma coisa
nova não é o bastante
a gente precisa usar melhor o que a
gente tem e usa mais e mais tempo e
consertar tem algum defeito faz um
ajuste em paralelo estão surgindo várias
outras formas de consumo hoje você já
pode pegar uma roupa emprestada no
armário compartilhado pagando uma
assinatura mensal diz ainda vou ver
pegar de novo no mês seguinte os eventos
de troca estão se tornando cada vez mais
recorrente
você leva uma sacola com que você não
quer mais e sair com novidades
sem precisar de nenhum dependente
financeiro ou demais acúmulo os brechós
hoje já tem uma experiência de butique e
na internet você consegue comprar e
vender peças de segunda mão e várias
opções de sites
se você que sabe fazer se você gosta
procure um tutorial faz você mesmo
customiza vai ter uma peça mais
exclusivo ainda é mais gratificante
a essa altura você já deve imaginar que
eu mudei de carreira né
hoje eu percebo que eu sou muito mais
feliz esperando as pessoas no meu
trabalho do que comprando tudo aquilo
que eu queria
hoje eu tenho mais empatia
eu tenho vontade de colaborar eu entendo
meu papel no todo e eu aprendi
que antes de sermos consumidores somos
cidadãos e nunca podemos trocar essa
ordem a e da próxima vez que vocês forem
comprar uma blusa pensar bem se é isso
mesmo que você precisa
ou seja um abraço
[Aplausos]
obrigada